objects it was the committee's 11th and
final public hearing the intention to
summarize its full report that will be
made public on Wednesday and to
highlight its belief that the former
president's actions were Criminal
no man who would behave that way at that
moment in time can ever serve in any
position of authority in our nation
again
he is unfit for any office
a video presentation served as a
reminder of the events on January the
6th 2021 and further extracts from some
of the hundreds of interviews the
committee conducted in an attempt to
find out what happened and how to
prevent it happening again there's one
factor I believe is most important in
preventing Another January 6th
accountability and the committee made
clear its opinion Trump must be held
accountable and will send a letter to
the justice department outlining its
reasons for recommending criminal
prosecution
Mr chairman on this vote there are nine
eyes and zero knows
the motion is agreed to the justice
department has so far prosecuted more
than 900 people in relation to the
events of January the 6th and to date
some 300 have been found guilty on the
first charge recommended against Donald
Trump obstruction of official
proceedings the justice department is
conducting its own investigation into
attempts by Donald Trump to overthrow
the results of the 2020 election and the
committee hopes that its findings will
provide a road map to the special
counsel who's in charge of that process
the committee has also recommended that
the actions of several Republican
members of Congress be referred to the
Ethics Committee for defying subpoenas
including two who will be vying for the
house Speaker position when the new
Congress convenes next month
but with the Republican majority in the
house that recommendation is unlikely to
be accepted and any decision to
attribute accountability for the
Insurrection Now lies solely with the
Department of Justice
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington